es el momento de analizar toda la
actualidad económica aquí en france 24
para ello contamos un día más con
nuestro compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido y vamos a comenzar hablando
de las consecuencias sobre la
alimentación mundial que supone la
guerra en ucrania y es que este
conflicto no pudo llegar en un peor
momento para la economía global varios
analistas agencias y organismos aseguran
que el mundo enfrenta varias crisis
combinadas que podrían derivar en una
emergencia alimentaria la guerra ya
afecta las exportaciones rusas y
ucranianas de productos básicos como el
trigo el aceite de girasol y el maíz
incidiendo en países de medio oriente y
áfrica del norte que dependen de las
importaciones de estos productos países
como el líbano que obtienen el 70 por
ciento de sus importaciones de trigo de
ucrania o si mencionamos a egipto el
mayor importador de trigo del mundo que
depende de rusia ucrania para alrededor
del 80% del trigo que compra en los
mercados internacionales
rodrigo y es que entre rusia y ucrania
producen el 30 por ciento del volumen
mundial de trigo y como son los
proveedores más baratos del mercado la
mayoría de sus exportaciones van a
países de bajos ingresos al 22 de marzo
los precios mundiales del trigo ya
habían subido un 19% producto de la
guerra en ucrania pero cuéntanos
exactamente cómo pone en riesgo la
alimentación global de esta guerra bueno
según reporte de la organización de las
naciones unidas para la agricultura y la
alimentación estima que los precios de
los alimentos podrían aumentar hasta en
un 20% en los próximos meses en marzo el
índice de precios de alimentos de la fao
subió un 12,6 por ciento frente a
febrero y se ubicó en los 159 tres
puntos la cifra más alta desde la
creación de la entidad de 1990 este
aumento es peligroso porque según el
programa mundial de alimentos casi 283
millones de personas de 81 países
enfrentan actualmente inseguridad
alimentaria aguda mientras que 45
millones de personas están al borde de
la hambruna también se debe mencionar
que ucrania fue la mayor fuente de
alimentos para el programa mundial de la
onu en 2021 los 45 países menos
desarrollados del mundo importan un
tercio de trigo desde los países en
guerra mientras 18 de estos países
importan
50% del trigo en esta lista entra egipto
la república democrática del congo libia
somalia sudán y yemen
marí pangestu quien es directora gerente
de política de desarrollo del banco
mundial pidió más acciones para hacer
frente al alza de los precios escuchemos
más no se trata tanto de la
disponibilidad de alimentos porque la
producción en este momento es adecuada
ya sea que hablemos de trigo arroz o
maíz que son los principales productos
alimenticios se trata más bien de la
asequibilidad esto significa realmente
esquemas de protección social en los
países más afectados para poder
proporcionar apoyo a los hogares pobres
para la alimentación y la nutrición y
luego para los agricultores para que
puedan asegurarse de que pueden tener
acceso a los fertilizantes e insumos
para que puedan producir para la próxima
temporada pues pueden existen pero jorge
hay otro problema que afecta también al
alza de los precios de los alimentos y
es la subida de los precios de los
fertilizantes y este problema está
vinculado a otro problema también que ya
venimos arrastrando antes de la guerra
inclusive que es el aumento de los
precios del gas y la energía por ejemplo
se necesita gas natural para fabricar
a componente clave de los fertilizantes
nitrogenados algunos productos de
fertilizantes como algunos productores
como ya era internacional en europa
recortaron su producción para hacer
frente al aumento de los precios este
gigante de los fertilizantes ha dicho
que el 80 por ciento del costo de
fabricación de fertilizantes a base de
nitrógeno proviene de la energía pero
además de los altos costos del gas y la
energía se debe tomar en cuenta que
rusia representa el 15 por ciento del
comercio mundial de fertilizantes
nitrogenados y el 17 por ciento de las
exportaciones mundiales de fertilizantes
potásicos por esto los precios de los
fertilizantes se encuentran en récord
histórico varios países de europa y área
y asia central dependen de rusia más del
50% para el suministro de sus
fertilizantes y aquí es donde el efecto
toca los puertos de américa latina por
ejemplo sobre todo en países como brasil
que importa el 85% de sus fertilizantes
la mayoría de rusia y ucrania brasil
argentina bolivia chile paraguay y
uruguay pidieron excluir los
fertilizantes de las sanciones
occidentales contra rusia previendo el
impacto que esto tendría para los este
aumento de precio de los fertilizantes
presiona la producción global de
alimentos y se verá reflejado en la
inflación que ya estaba al alza antes de
la guerra como consecuencia de la
pandemia escuchemos un poco hartford
making aparte de asegurarnos que el
flujo de bienes no se vea obstaculizados
tenemos que asegurarnos de que la
asequibilidad de los alimentos para los
hogares pobres también va a ser abordada
la caída de la producción de alimentos
en esta región ha sido un problema
relacionado con el cambio climático
incluso antes de la crisis así que
podemos centrarnos al mismo tiempo en
asegurarnos de que se hace un uso
eficiente de los fertilizantes de las
prácticas agrícolas sostenibles y de que
se aborda la cuestión de la seguridad a
largo plazo que se jorge aunque no nos
guste lo que hemos escuchado muy buena y
muy completa esta crónica económica de
hoy muchas gracias por estar en este
plato ya nuestros telespectadores los
invitamos a que sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]